A
COMPLETE TRANSFORMATION OF THE
GLOBAL ENERGY SYSTEM.
THE POLICY ARE NOT JUST
DESTROYING LIVES, THEY ARE ROAD
TRIP IN LIES ALL OF THEM.
OUR NEXT GUEST WAS A CLIMATE
ALARMIST BUT NOW SAYS THE
MOVEMENT IS A SCAM.
HE IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECT OF
THE INTERNATIONAL SCIENCE
CLIMATE COALITION.
YOU SAY THE ONLY WAY TO GET RID
OF THIS IS TO GO AFTER THE
SCIENCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
EXPLAIN.
>> EXACTLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL SAY WELL,
CANADA PUTS OUT SO LITTLE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
THE TROUBLE IS PEOPLE ARGUE WE
HAVE TO SET AN EXAMPLE TO THE
WORLD AND BE GOOD CITIZENS.
THEY USING ARGUMENTS THAT THE
CHINA DOUBLES THE EMISSIONS OF
THE U.S.
BUT THERE IS NO CLIMATE CRISIS.
I WAS AN AEROSPACE ENGINEER.
I WROTE ARTICLES ABOUT STUDYING
THE PLANET HELPS US UNDERSTAND
THE EARTH BETTER.
I USED THE EXAMPLE THE RUN AWAY
GREENHOUSE EFFECT ON
CONVENIENCE.
I -- VENUS.
THIS COULD HAPPEN ON THE EARTH.
A LOCAL PROFESSOR LIKED MY
ARTICLE SO MUCH HE USED IT IN
HIS COURSE ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT HE SAID TO THE STUDENTS,
THAT PART ABOUT VENUS IS WRONG.
WHAT HAPPENED ON VENUS CAN'T
HAPPEN ON THE EARTH AND
EXPLAINED WHY.
I THOUGHT WHO IS THIS CLIMATE
CHANGE DENIER?
HE INVITED ME INTO THE LAB AND
SHOWED ME THE HISTORY THEY ARE
FINDING AND THERE WAS NO
CORRELATION BETWEEN CARBON
DIOXIDE AND EARTH'S
TEMPERATURES.
I STARTED WONDERING, MAYBE ME IS
RIGHT.
HE EXPOSED ME TO PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED ME THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
SCIENTISTS AND THIS BOOK
ILLUSTRATES THIS.
CLIMATE CHANGE RECONSIDERED.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
REFERENCES WHICH TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THERE IS NO FOUNDATION TO
THE CLIMATE SCARE.
IT'S BASED ON MODELS THAT DON'T
WORK.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU HEAR POLITICO
AND CELEBRITIES, SCIENCE IS
SETTLED.
IF SCIENCE EVER SETTLED?
>> NO.
>> Laura: WE KNOW WHAT H2-0 IS.
>> THIS IS AN IMMATURE SCIENCE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT WILL
WARM OR COOL.
PEOPLE STUDYING THE SUN SO HE
ARE HEADED INTO A GRAND SOLAR
MINIMUM IN '60 AND WILL COOL
DOWN.
THE ONLY APPROACH IS GET READY
FOR IT AND MAKE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENED AND USE
DEPENDABLE ENERGY LIKE COAL.
NOT TO TURN OFF RELIABLE ENERGY
FOR FLIMSY WIND AND ENERGY
POWER.
I AM IN BASED IN OTTAWA.
THEY ARE RUNNING AN APPLICATION.
IT'S -- ELECTION.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BRING IN
A CLIMATE ALARMIST AS MAYOR.
THEY HAVE CLIMATE ACTIVISTS
RUNNING THE DEBATE.
>> Laura: IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
IT'S HAPPENING IN CANADA AND IN
THE UNITED STATE